un dirigible lleno de helio flota porque
el helio es menos denso que el aire y
entonces el helio sube la densidad del
helio es aproximadamente 1.1 kilogramos
por metro cúbico menos que la del aire
lo cual quiere decir que un metro cúbico
de helio puede levantar aproximadamente
1.1 kilogramos voy a marcar eso en azul
y déjame explicarlo un poquito sí aquí
tenemos un metro cúbico de helio lo voy
a pintar como un cubo
algo así y de este lado a la derecha
tenemos un metro cúbico de aire también
lo voy a pintar como un cubo imagínate
que son de él del mismo tamaño vale
entonces nos están diciendo que el helio
pesa 1.1 kilogramos menos que esta
cantidad de aire y justo eso es lo que
le permite cargar cosas como hay una
diferencia de densidad es entonces el
helio sube y sube y puede cargar
exactamente esa diferencia de masas vale
bueno entonces nos están diciendo que
puede levantar 1.1 kilogramos y nos
dicen que un dirigible con masa de 2.11
por 10 a la 5 kilogramos puede llevar 2
por 10 a las 5 metros cúbicos de helio
bar si la masa promedio de una persona
con equipaje es de 10 al cuadrado
kilogramos cuál es la cantidad de
pasajeros que puede cargar el dirigible
ok te recomiendo que detengas el vídeo y
que intentes este problema por tu cuenta
una pequeña pista es la siguiente
sabiendo cuánto helio puede llevar el
dirigible puedes saber cuánto puede
cargar porque aquí
cuanto carga cada metro cúbico y ya que
sabes cuánto puede cargar en total el
dirigible primero debe cargarse a sí
mismo y luego con lo que sobre ya puede
cargar a las personas sale esa es la
pista voy a suponer que ahorita ya
intentaste resolver el problema y voy a
empezar a hacerlo lo primero que vamos a
hacer es ver cuánto puede cargar el
dirigible en total es decir cuánto puede
cargar esta cantidad de helio déjame
ponerle por aquí que son dos por diez a
las cinco a las cinco metros cúbicos de
helio bueno esta es la cantidad de helio
que tenemos y además nos dicen que cada
metro cúbico de helio entonces hay que
multiplicar cada metro cúbico de helio
puede cargar 1.1 kilogramos 1.1
kilogramos por metro cúbico vamos a
hacer este producto sería 2 por 1.1 2
por 1.1 es 2.2
todos luego eso hay que multiplicarlo
por diez a las cinco por diez a las
cinco y vamos a ver que nos queda en las
unidades
aquí metros cúbicos se cancela con
metros cúbicos y nos queda hasta el
final kilogramos eso está muy bien
verdad el análisis de unidades el
análisis dimensional quedó bien porque
justo queríamos ver cuál es la cantidad
de masa que puede cargar entonces esto
es lo que puede cargar lo que puede
puede cargar
bueno pero esto que puede cargar no lo
puede utilizar totalmente en cargar
personas primero debe de cargarse a sí
mismo el dirigible entonces tenemos que
restar la masa del dirigible 2.11 por 10
a las 5 kilogramos entonces a esto
déjame restarle 2.11 por 10 a las 5 10 a
las 5 kilogramos kilogramos va una vez
que hagamos esta resta podemos saber
cuánto sobra para cargar personas
entonces déjame restar voy a hacer de
este lado 2.2 menos 2.11 ok
2 - 20 aquí podemos poner un 0 20 menos
11 es 9 entonces nos queda 0.09 de modo
que aquí queda 0.09 multiplicado por 10
a las 5 10 a las 5 kilogramos y ahora si
todo esto se puede utilizar en cargar
personas y cómo le hacemos para ver
cuántas personas o vaya a personas con
equipajes se pueden cargar pues
simplemente dividimos
esto entre la cantidad o entre la masa
promedio de personas con equipaje vamos
a ver qué queda entonces déjame dividir
vamos a dividir entre 10 al cuadrado
kilogramos por persona por persona nada
más le voy a poner personas pero
acuérdate que es persona con equipaje
bueno que nos queda esta división si
hacemos esta división nos queda 10 a las
5 entre 10 a la 2 que sería 10 al cubo
pieza al cubo y aquí nos quedaría 0.09
0.09 0.09 por 10 al cubo y en las
unidades que nos quedan pues sería
kilogramos dividido entre kilogramos por
persona que es lo mismo a tomar
kilogramos y multiplicarlo por personas
dividido entre kilogramos si dividir
entre algo es lo mismo que multiplicar
por su recíproco entonces kilogramos se
cancela con kilogramos y las unidades
quedan personas lo cual es fantástico
porque si justamente estábamos
preguntándonos por la
de pasajeros de personas con equipaje
que se pueden cargar entonces sería esta
cantidad que podemos simplificar la
verdad multiplicar por 10 al cubo es
recorrer el punto decimal tres veces a
la derecha 0.09 nos quedaría aquí
recorrido una vez aquí recorrido otra
vez y para recorrer otra vez necesitamos
poner un cero entonces sería 90 me voy a
poner por acá que esto es igual esto es
igual a 90 90 personas entonces este
dirigible que tiene masa de 2.11 por 10
a las 5 kilogramos y que puede cargar 2
por 10 a las 5 metros cúbicos de helio
puede cargar puede cargar a 90 personas
con equipaje